[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're discussing the life
of a certain hogwarts founder let's get
into it
if you think about the greatest founder
of hogwarts who comes to mind if you
value overall magical abilities you
might be tempted to choose salazar
sutherin
after all he created a secret enchanted
chamber right under the noses of the
three other original teachers at the
school and none of them ever found out
but if you are fascinated by the legacy
of wizards who triumphed over dark
sorcerers you'd likely suggest godric
gryffindor
the students who enrolled in his house
were among the strongest wizards in all
of europe and in the 20th century
gryffindor students were responsible for
defeating not just grindelwald but also
the far more terrifying dark wizard tom
riddle i'd imagine even a few of you
would throw out rowena ravenclaw as your
choice unlike the other founders robina
wasn't interested in courage or pure
blood she chose her students based on
their intelligence
the greatest wondermaker in the world
the man responsible for giving both lord
voldemort and harry potter the tools
they needed to jewel garrick ollivander
was actually a graduate of rowena's
house but i'm willing to claim that
helga hufflepuff the fourth and last
founder of hogwarts might actually have
been greater than all the rest
why well that's what we're going to talk
about today when we look at her life and
legacy
just like the other founders of hogwarts
helga hufflepuff represented a unique
part of the british isles godric
gryffindor was born in the west country
of england robbing a ravenclaw in a
narrow valley within the scottish
countryside and salazar sutherin in
ireland
although that last part is often
contested but helga just like one of the
most unique indigenous creatures in
britain the green welsh dragons hailed
from wales although the ancient records
of her hometown have been lost we know
that helga was raised far away from the
urban trading centers that boarded
england and instead grew up deep within
the welsh countryside amidst its flowing
creeks and low rolling hills considering
how great of an influence the birthplace
of hogwarts other founders played in
their roles as teachers it's surprising
to note that helga hufflepuff's welsh
heritage might have merely been a
footnote for the highly regarded witch
gryffindor despite his reputation as one
of the most noble sorcerers of his time
had a particularly bad habit of eagerly
jumping into jewels that trait courage
in the face of possible death was the
very thing the sorting had to search for
when selecting students for godric's
house and historians have often cited
gryffindor's english heritage and his
life in the small town that would
eventually bear his name godric's hollow
as the landscape that molded his bravery
even sutherin who was rumored to move
about quite often first starting an
island and eventually making his way to
gryffindor's village was shaped by his
home having faced the sharp-tongued
jeers of muggles who feared the magical
community slytherin developed a deep
hatred for any non-magical being this
prejudice of course later got him kicked
out of hogwarts but it is another trait
that historians have attached to the
landscape he was raised in when we think
of helga hufflepuff her greatest
attribute was her fair and kind heart
when we talk about her time as a teacher
at hogwarts we'll dive into what helga's
fairness actually meant in terms of her
students
although we know helga's birthplace it's
impossible to know her actual birth date
like the other founders of hogwarts and
pretty much anyone else from the
wizarding world at the time
surviving parchment records are hard to
come by
the best we can do is look at the
founding date of hogwarts and deduce how
old helga must have been at the time
now we know that hogwarts was
established in the year 993 just a few
short years of the turn of the
millennium
certainly helga hufflepuff was born at
least a few decades before but it's
deciphering exactly how long prior that
gets tricky but since we know that
helger godrick salazar and rowena are
often cited as being close friends then
they must have been similar in age and
since most are rumored to have died in
the 11th or 12th century it's likely
that helga was in her 30s or 40s during
the first few semesters which would make
her birth date sometime around 9 60 ce
as a co-founder of hogwarts hufflepuff
must have been among the greatest
witches of her era
when we look at her particular skills we
find that she excelled at one of the
lesser celebrated magical disciplines
food charms although you might be quick
to dismiss this art form you'd be wrong
to do so hufflepuff's ability to create
massive feasts and decadent desserts
with her wand wouldn't help in a battle
against dark wizard that's a fair point
certainly but food charms are one of the
most important parts of daily wizarding
life if you think about it carefully
you'd realize that the magical
community's ability to quickly
efficiently and hygienically prepare
food throughout the middle ages was
something that clearly separated it from
the muggle world
non-magical users often suffered various
diseases and even plagues throughout
much of early history
some sicknesses were caused by spoiled
food while other ailments were spread to
food stores by diseased vermin it wasn't
until the advent of modern medicine
during the 20th century and the
technological revolution that spawned
refrigeration that food-related
illnesses stopped being a leading cause
of death among children and adults aged
18 to 50
but throughout all of those centuries
the wizarding community was mostly
unaffected
of course even during helga's time
healing magic was quite adept at curing
mundane diseases like the flu or common
cold so even if a wizard contracted a
food-related illness it's likely that
they would be able to treat it with a
few swings of their wand but that
doesn't take away from a simple fact
hufflepuff pushed food charms far beyond
what they were before her
and likely saved lives doing so her
fellow co-founders obviously valued her
magical contributions when they deemed
hufflepuff wise enough to help them join
in creating hogwarts
and it was during her time at hogwarts
that helga's vision for the future
created a legacy that helped more
wizards than any of her peers and is the
main reason you'd be right to call her
the greatest of them all
as we mentioned earlier part of the
rights given to each founder was how
exactly to pick students for their
respective houses just as each founder
excelled in a particular magical
discipline they each desired their
pupils who reflected that
godric valued courage salazar favored
purebloods and rowena accepted the most
intelligent students but helga was
different
she allowed anyone in she didn't hold
any bias against her students and she
didn't allow any of her preconceived
notions of a young boy or girl to get in
the way of how a formal magical
education could transform their future
and in that way helga touched the lives
of thousands of wizards who would have
otherwise been rejected by the other
houses
at most helga simply wanted good honest
children who would work hard and remain
loyal to their friends even though the
other houses produced far more famous
graduates it's hard to imagine any of
them producing a greater message than
helga
hogwarts was a school after all and not
a factory for pumping out heroic wizards
or evil dark sorcerers
if we simply analyze helga hufflepuff at
face value as a teacher and school
founder then her methods just don't seem
like they can be beat after founding the
school years passed as helga taught
fresh new faces every fall
but just as godric gryffindor and rowena
ravenclaw would eventually come to
understand helga started to feel like
one of her co-founders was meddling in
dark magic
in time salazar slytherin would approach
the other founders and request that they
change their admittance standards
salazar still deeply scarred by the
torment he likely suffered at the hands
of muggles wanted to bar half bloods and
muggle borns from enrolling in hogwarts
but the other founders refused to cede
to slytherin's demands and knowing how
staunch an egalitarian hufflepuff turned
out to be it's likely that she was the
one leading the charge against salazar
eventually southern left the school and
the remaining three headmasters carried
on without him
fortunately for helga the rest of her
life was uneventful and the small schism
with salazar was the last large
confrontation she had to suffer
she passed sometime in the 11th or 12th
century
although this date too has been lost in
time when we look at the legacy of helga
hufflepuff's education philosophy and to
the school that bore her name it's easy
to see that in some ways she truly was
ahead of her peers most of the graduates
of house hufflepuff were level-headed
reasonable young men and women
although many of them never became
powerful duelists or dark wizards like
the graduates of gryffindor or slytherin
the hufflepuff alumni shouldn't be
ashamed of themselves some of them like
artemisia lufkin and grogan stamp both
former ministers for magic went on to
better the wizarding world in
conventional but meaningful ways and
that's it for this video if you want to
know the history of the other three
founders i've made videos on them as
well as always please like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you enjoy
the content until next time remember
imperfect understanding is often more
dangerous than ignorance
[Music]
you